Komputasi kuantum sudah memasuki era utilitas
yang artinya kita bisa mulai pakai komputer kuantum untuk menyelesaikan
masalah nyata di dunia, termasuk yang sangat sulit
buat komputer klasik
tema umum di era sekarang ini
adalah suatu masalah berhasil dipecahkan
untuk pertama kalinya di komputer kuantum
lalu kemudian orang-orang nemuin cara buat ngelakuinnya di komputer klasik
siklus komputasi klasik ini
dan kuantum yang saling mendorong satu sama lain ke batas
kemampuannya kemungkinan akan terus berlanjut
beberapa tahun ke depan ada kelas-kelas masalah di mana kuantum
bisa punya keunggulan yang bisa dibuktikan
dibanding komputasi klasik
seiring kemajuan di bidang-bidang seperti
pengurangan error dan jumlah qubit yang tersedia
ada juga seluruh area aplikasi
di mana komputasi kuantum
mungkin berguna dalam jangka waktu yang relatif dekat
salah satunya adalah quantum machine learning atau QML
quantum machine learning mengacu pada
penerapan komputasi kuantum ke semua jenis machine
learning tentunya ada banyak
jenis machine learning
dua jenis yang paling menarik adalah
supervised learning di mana kamu
melatih algoritma pakai dataset berlabel
dan unsupervised learning di mana
algoritma bekerja dari sampel tanpa label
dan mencoba mempelajari distribusinya
atau fungsi yang menghasilkannya
algoritma unsupervised mungkin
misalnya belajar cara menghasilkan sampel baru
dari distribusi yang sama atau cara
mengelompokkan sampel ke dalam grup dengan karakteristik serupa
baik supervised maupun unsupervised learning sering melibatkan
penyematan data di ruang berdimensi lebih tinggi
dan manipulasi data di ruang berdimensi lebih tinggi
seharusnya mengingatkan kita pada komputasi kuantum
biar lebih jelas, bayangkan mencoba memecahkan masalah apakah
harus mengklasifikasikan titik data dari bidang
sebagai lingkaran atau silang berdasarkan data pelatihan berlabel di sini
kadang data bisa dipisahkan dengan jelas oleh sebuah garis
atau bidang dalam dimensi rendah
seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini dan mengklasifikasikan titik-titik data ini
ke yang di atas garis
dan di bawah garis harusnya
gampang saja tapi lihat distribusi ini
jelas tidak ada garis yang terlihat yang memisahkan titik-titik data
tapi untuk data ini kita bisa bayangkan semacam
pemetaan dari dua dimensi ke tiga dimensi
sehingga setelah menerapkan pemetaan tersebut data kita terlihat
seperti ini dan jelas ada bidang yang memisahkan keduanya
kelas-kelas yang bisa kita gunakan
untuk klasifikasi kalau penjelasan ini terasa terlalu sederhana
kamu benar kita tidak bisa begitu saja menaruh titik data yang kita mau
lebih ke atas tanpa alasan yang jelas
harus ada pemetaan
dari distribusi 2D yang secara efektif memisahkan
titik-titik data kita sehingga kita bisa
pakai pemetaan itu untuk mengklasifikasikan titik data baru
ini akan dibahas lebih lanjut di pelajaran yang membahas
rekap machine learning tapi cukup dikatakan
bahwa masalahnya bisa dilihat
sebagai mencoba berbagai pemetaan yang berbeda ke ruang berdimensi lebih tinggi
untuk melihat pemetaan mana yang menghasilkan
pemisahan terbaik titik data dari kelas yang berbeda
manipulasi data di dimensi yang lebih tinggi ini
adalah salah satu area di mana komputasi kuantum
mungkin punya dampak besar untuk memahami kenapa
mari kita kembali ke perbedaan antara klasik
dan komputasi kuantum sama seperti
komputer klasik menggunakan bit informasi
komputer kuantum menggunakan qubit
tapi untuk jumlah bit tertentu, misalnya empat
komputer klasik bisa mengambil salah satu dari
dua pangkat empat atau enam belas kemungkinan state
komputer kuantum juga bisa mengakses enam belas kemungkinan state
tapi bisa ada dalam superposisi dari semua
enam belas state secara bersamaan
dan operasi bisa dilakukan pada seluruh superposisi ini
untuk empat qubit ini mungkin kelihatannya
bukan hal yang besar tapi bayangkan apa yang bisa dilakukan dengan
komputer kuantum dalam dua pangkat dua puluh atau
dua pangkat seratus dua puluh tujuh
state sekaligus ada banyak perbedaan lain
antara komputasi klasik dan kuantum yang akan
semuanya berperan dalam topik ini
state kuantum punya amplitudo probabilitas kompleks
manipulasi sistem kuantum dilakukan dengan
operator uniter dan komputer kuantum rentan terhadap jenis
noise yang berbeda dari komputer klasik
perbedaan-perbedaan ini akan muncul
di seluruh pekerjaan quantum machine learning kamu di area-area
seperti encoding data, feature mapping, dan mitigasi error
dalam beberapa kasus perbedaan antara klasik
dan komputer kuantum memungkinkan kita untuk merancang
algoritma-algoritma baru nah itu tadi gambaran singkat
tentang perpaduan dua bidang yang sangat kompleks
tapi semoga dua hal sudah jelas
machine learning sering memecahkan masalah
dengan memanipulasi data di dimensi yang sangat tinggi
dan kedua komputer kuantum sangat cocok
untuk memanipulasi data di dimensi tinggi
dan melakukannya dengan cara yang berbeda dari sistem klasik
ini seharusnya memberi kamu gambaran
mengapa machine learning adalah bidang yang menjanjikan
untuk penerapan komputasi kuantum yang berguna